that was like an outlet pass and a Miss
free-throw nice fine to the corner long
two-pointer for Dudley fouls repeat the
lemons Russell to the corner Dudley he's
got it it's a three I promise you
there's no place i'd rather be night in
here with the yes Noah
that was my sensitive so yeah that's so
sweet released by Joe Harris a circus
ship to a freighter under seven minutes
to go here in the third that's up like
14 tack out two more perish the cut to
the rim and Russell rewards it lock the
gate down a little bit more to beat into
his strength
just trying to duck to the basket again
so it's Redax job there to pet bounce
the ball just played an extra second
nice decision for Russell jared allen
finish it
shot clock working against them down to
two on the cut levert able to finish
another 20 point night for Kara sliver
and you go back to what DeAngelo Russell
have done I mean over the course of the
last four games 19 assists three
turnovers and another assist there as
levert lays it in in this first half
Mandy a tied at 44 levert goes backdoor
and skies in for two nice dish from
Russia's Russell holding off Gill just
alexander skies alyce caron out at with
seven early points two seconds to go
harris off to be from russell six-point
lead
Utah leads at 4:00 to grab moving
without the ball Mitchell sticking with
him give and go Russell give it back
Jared Allen finishes well execute
internet now this honesty is rewarded
with a steel lane
[Music]
and Jared Allen can't run write a new
chapter to their fourth quarter saga
started the quarter down five have now
tied it a chance to go in front
Billy Russell to Carroll on I know Roy
and then Russell a beautiful bounce pass
to finish things up
Russell gonna have to make something
happen two to shoot Russell finds a leg
he got it off in time with the
left-handed slam on a gorgeous dime from
Russell December 17 Sarah oh I meant to
gotcha
Russell leads Dinwiddie hey finishes
big-time play out of the timeout there
for Kenny a consent good stuff Michael
caldwell-pope nails the jump shot out of
the timeout Davis
wheeling to the rim D'Angelo Russell 7
of 13 from the field 17 points 6 assists
ku roots it's a three four team fouls on
sucks already' Russell lobs it up and
Allen throws it down and here's an
opportunity to go upstairs you got it to
get it over the big guy to begin with
look at Jared Allen get Russell snatches
the rebound and Joe Harris up on the
right there he is into corner take a
straight game with at least three threes
for Joe Harris look at Joe Harris now
he's setting his feet up you see him
lining it up facing up then it's a
matter of catching guffawed rou-ha-nee
the these first two possessions just out
there playing he's not really looking to
get anybody involved he just kind of
shoot ball juggling three typically
wants to create and then great pass by
D'Angelo stringing out Julius Randle and
that make into making it an easy shot
three minutes gone by here in the first
we're also using the Allen screen kick
packs of three Joe Harris turned in the
Russell Hicks in Paris Paris finish
gorgeous design and delivery Russell the
hair Boston cuts it to to Russell fine
talent for the throw flush or a shot
clock again winding down Morris misses
and the long rebound to Russell Seminole
runs for Brooklyn what a feed DeAngelo
Russell incredible vision but Russell
great job of his taking his time probing
and Jared Allen running right through
the middle Papa John's and the nets
control it Russell on the outside finds
the career Jared Allen back to the
perimeter
jared allen left-handed crank again and
again job we talked about in the opening
just the ankles ability to find
everybody and today no cleared by allen
attached to a no against the walls watch
this little cut a top bang he's done
marketing is out of position defensively
it's in with the bulls
he's looking for a trade chicago looking
a deal ed davis up top on a special
delivery by DeAngelo Russell Russell
blob it up Allen the cash the release
one Jared Allen chance for three match
on the inside he's coming off of that
screen Danny Green is going to be the
one that has got a country and Davis
all of a slip to the Jared Allen done
contestants Jam for Brooklyn
let's get into it quickly here and
Russell find a rhythm isolation dumps it
inside Allen lays it in great field by P
Angelo Russell one point scuse me and
it's just all random it just he just
finds ways to score hollis-jefferson
gets the roll on the inside gonna make
changes on the floor with two routes and
Davis along with Napier getting ready to
check in Russell drops it to Allen Carr
chance for three eagle Richard Jefferson
Michael Grady the rest of our crew Bob
Lorenz and Jim span are cold in the
house as well
lob it up
I'm the Throwdown nancial bridge look at
this just a perfect law you run this
play out of a timeout these are the need
plays coaches have you know three-point
shot twenty nine point loss at the hands
of Miami on Saturday night Brian Forte
Scott for da ski and Jason Goldberg the
official hard to the hole yeah he had to
get off the board I feel like this crowd
wanted to make a shot at this point I'm
Russell can't just that little left over
the top you got a go at D'Angelo but
Jared Allen does a great job getting
behind pal and if you're late you might
as well not even be there he's having
his most consistent season and the
patience shown by Dwayne Casey look out
off the law ku roots to finish it grows
beautiful yes yes one day you'll explain
to me the difference between micro and
macro who routes the cut Russell found
of the chemistry between those two which
is to get to halfway two points or feels
like you're just not scoring on pace
with stems Russell Hobbs and open a lien
oops the alley go underneath because if
you go over the top you got to bring a
lot already and play so when you run
that zone it kind of confuses the team
and a lot of times causes a turnover
Cowen hell you pay used to see this in
LA all the time but he was Chris Paul to
put Russell pull-up jumper short cool
roots came flying in to keep it alive
nice look for Russell in Davis County
death lobs it up oops the alley that
no-look deliver here is that beauty
Jared Allen realizing that there's two
players collapsing in on D'Angelo
Russell off that screen so just slips
right through the middle a beautiful
pass by D'Angelo Russell Barnes burner
going on here night guys whoo both teams
shooting 33% or worse as Davis pounds
the rim on the delivery from Russell I
could Russell find Allen to the rim back
to that first play of the half of the
pick-and-roll Russell the Nets first
basket in history I think so maybe not
this season Harry's there
and there is Portland here we go Joe
Harris irate on the horn
big old pads ruffles Angela Russell
doing a good job bobbing up and that's
exactly what you want to see the lake
recovery time they lost Harris on a cut
to the rim and Russell nails them with a
pass Pacers own for two to start with
three turnovers and now they throw it
inside and ku roots ducks at home it's
not nothing what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content